did you know Antonio Banderas refuses to
think of the lead character in Puss in
Boots as a cat and that John Mulaney
refers to his character Jack Horner as
kind of a psychopath these are just some
of the fun Revelations I have in store
for you as we dive into the voice actors
who made Puss and Boots The Last Wish a
hilarious and heartwarming story Antonio
Banderas used to be known mostly as that
hunky actor who made everybody Swoon
with his accent and general Aura you can
make anything sound sexy and sure that's
all still true the guy has six releases
in 2023 alone including a turn in the
latest Indiana Jones movie but in the
past couple of decades he's also become
a go-to voice actor what started out as
a smaller role in the Shrek Universe the
shrekiverse the universe Shrek I don't
know as Puss in Boots in Shrek 2 has
expanded to appearances in many
DreamWorks releases let's just say this
man has owned the character for a while
now interestingly enough he he was
originally asked to consider voicing the
role with a high-pitched voice but he
and the other creatives decided on a
more breathy and deep tone giving the
character more gravitas and that's
probably helpful because apparently
Antonio has quite a different way of
approaching his character I don't treat
my character like a cat I treat my
character like a human because he talks
well he's certainly right that puss
talks because otherwise they probably
wouldn't need his voice acting anyway he
clearly adores the process and finds it
very creatively fulfilling plus when you
see clips of him in the studio voicing
the character it's pretty obvious he's
having the time of his life do you mind
I'm trying to eat it I mean meow
whatever and why shouldn't he the
character is hilarious the movies are
classic and he's probably receiving Nine
Lives worth of paychecks for the gig
another feline friend of the universe
Shrek is it catching on no okay cool is
Kitty Soft Paws played by the inimitable
Salma Hayek though technically these
days she goes by her married name Salma
Hayek Pino sure add on a gorgeous just
French name to make you even more
perfect Salma anyway she thinks Puss and
Boots The Last Wish is better than the
previous offerings I think this one is
the best one and she talks about the
reasons the latest one is the best
especially in terms of creating and
living in her character we release spend
the time to explore the characters it
was never just saying lines and she
really loved the fact that they were
able to take their time rehearse and get
to know the nuances of the story and the
characters in fact she thinks they were
able to do that more than in a regular
non-animated film sometimes in a regular
film that people are not rehearsing
anymore everything is Hari Hari Hari and
frankly even if the filming was rushed
she would have had a great time because
Salma freely admits to adoring her role
I love my character of kirisoft well
right back at you Sama you can do no
wrong and I won't hear otherwise now you
might expect that Goldilocks would be
another adored character because you
know she's Goldilocks but DreamWorks
flipped that on its head and asked
Florence Pugh to voice this classic
character as one of puss's evil foes in
The Last Wish Florence embraced her
inner Lock Stock and Two Smoking Barrels
character and basically admitted that
good old Goldie has very much taken a
turn for the worse Deluxe has been
adopted by the Bears the Bears have made
her into this kind of like gangster's
daughter and Flo leaned into the part
experimenting with her best Cockney
accent and gangster Flair she even gave
a little special oomph to the non-word
elements of the recording oh okay
plus she admitted to using some of her
own family history has a great way into
the chaos and edginess of the character
and the scenes she's in Miss Pugh seems
to be one of those actresses who can
fully go good and then fully go evil and
we will believe all of it on the
opposite side of the character spectrum
is pero AKA perito an ever-positive Joy
of a therapy puppy voiced by Harvey
guillot Harvey Defoe had fun in the
booth doing this movie oh this is great
razzing and Riven and barbin and pooping
and student the man is basically
designed to play a character whose goal
it is to make everyone's day better I
mean he admitted to being so happy being
in the movie it made every day feel
sunny outside even when it wasn't and
even on days that it was like cloudy I
still felt this like Vibe of goodness it
just put me in a good mood and at the
same time the character of Jack Horner
pretty much has the opposite effect
voiced by John Mulaney Jack is well
troubled in one interview John
sugarcoated it but in another he just
just came out with it it's kind of a
psychopath and of course John has doubts
that Jack will ever change Jack Horner
will never be happy but at least it
definitely seemed like Jon had a ton of
fun voicing Jack giving that trademarked
mullany old-timey lilt to the character
and of course the opposite of an
old-timey lilt is definitely the deep
voice dynamism that Wagner Mora used to
voice the big bad wolf not too
surprisingly this version of the big bad
wolf is a bounty hunter though not the
kind you root for like Boba Fett he's
definitely on the evil side of the
street and Wagner Mora kills it as this
deep voiced Baddie oh well if isn't Puss
in Boots himself not only that he
definitely has respect for the part it's
really cool to play one of the greatest
villains in The Fairy Tale Universe
although he tried not to get too bogged
down in the bad part of playing a bad
guy Wagner still found the levity in the
character and the situations he's
involved in all of the characters are
very funny okay I'm gonna go re-watch
this movie and then if there's time for
dinner all the other Puss in Boots
movies and the Shrek movies okay fine
maybe I'll skip dinner priorities right
have any thoughts about the voice cast
of Puss and Boots The Last Wish pop them
in the comment section
foreign